charlotte gould from phoenix arizona is
making headlines for her line of custom
companion dolls
which are designed to comfort children
who are preparing
for or recovering from surgery
please welcome the ceo of stitches by
charlotte
it's charlotte hi
drew how are you
i'm incredible thank you may i ask
how did you start making companion dolls
and then start making them for other
children i was born with a cloth
flipping palette which means part of my
upper lip
and the roof of my mouth were missing
when i was born i had to go through a
lot of surgeries
to get to where my smile is today but i
absolutely love
my smile then when i was seven i got a
sewing machine for christmas from my
nana
and i learned how to sew so i made a
doll that looked just like me it even
had a little scar on its lip
around that time i found out that my
dance teacher was pregnant
but her baby was only going to be born
with half of a heart
so i made an extra special doll for her
that had stitches
on the babies are on the doll's chest
and you actually can show people how to
customize
these dolls themselves if they want to
give it to someone is that right
um okay so i'm gonna pick up my doll you
have a bow here
i i'm feeling a bow tie for her for some
reason
okay what i like to do is make sure i
have it in the position i want it
and then i like to bring the needle
through the fabric
and pull it up a little bit of a
distance away
after i have the bow positioned
charlotte
when i heard your story it reminded me
of a friend of mine and her name is
addison
and she's battling a condition called
colitis
which affects your intestines and
when addison has been in the hospital
sometimes i've sent you know balloons or
little different packages that i thought
would cheer her up
and then when i heard about your
companion dolls i sort of put
the two of you together in my mind and
heart so i wanted to introduce you if
that's okay
that would be wonderful addison honey
are you there
yes
[Applause]
how are you doing i'm doing good
oh you're such a cutie pie you look so
beautiful addison
how did you feel um when you got your
doll i felt really happy and
i felt really excited you're so brave
for everything that you go through and
you do and you're just so strong and
your strength
has been a major impact on my life and
when your dad sends me pictures
the smile i see on your face is like
it's just
it makes life make sense to me and
charlotte
you have come up with this whole
business model and plan
to make it a more comfortable cheerful
and you know connective experience
okay i just finished my bow tie
which is sideways i didn't even know it
could do that
um it looks really nice oh
charlotte see that's why you started
this wonderful company is because you
know how to make people feel
good addison i hope your dog gives you
so much bravery and so many smiles
thank you i have to say charlotte
addison
is one of the bravest young women that i
know
and it has been such a pleasure to know
her and her family over the years
and charlotte you are the kind of person
that makes
life make sense to me and i love
business and i love taking care of
people
and you are the shining example of
bringing those two things together and i
know that
each one of your dolls costs 40 dollars
and that you donate a portion of the
proceeds
to the cleft lip research so our friends
at the craft and fabric retailer joanne
heard about your story and they are
sending you a 5 000
gift card so that you can continue
making your companion dolls
for children who need a little more
charlotte and these beautiful companion
dolls in their life
thank you so much thank you
always to our friends at joann you
always step up to the plate
and charlotte we're going to be
featuring your cause
and your business on our website and in
our small
business guide so that we can continue
to support everything that you're doing
and addison thank you so much for
joining us today because you've been an
important person in my life over the
years
you're welcome and your beauty and your
strength and your bravery
charlotte and addison you are my heroes
thank you so much
thank you thank you so much